[Music]
where did
things now
are at somewhat of an impasse a violent
impasse that is people in the streets
they're they're staying out there in
protest burning tyres blocking off roads
by by laying rocks you know uprooting
roads brick walls across roads in the
capital harpoon many people now injured
some even killed and what they demand is
that the military
stay out of civilian business they
demand the release of all the ministers
the civilian
leaders that have been arrested by the
military
over the past
two days the military says that this
power sharing agreement between this
transitional agreement between the
military and civilian leaders it hasn't
worked and they have uh have recently
been backed by other people also
civilians who say that things were
better uh under the dictate the or
autocrat omar bashir who ruled the
country for three decades and who was
deposed by public protests in 2019
we've seen reaction pouring
internationally the united states has
said that 700 million dollars in
financing assistance for the country has
been suspended frozen for now pending
the the actions of the military they
want them to release all the civilian
leaders that they've arrested they've
also uh condemned it and said that they
had no warning that this coup was
in the works to be clear um we were not
given any heads up about this there is
no
um
uh us military footprint on the ground
in sudan there's no training it's not
like this disrupted some sort of
training partnership or relationship
there there's no we don't have a u.s
military presence on the ground to those
ends condemnation has also poured in
from from the european union various uh
countries that make it up also the arab
league the african union there is some
talk that perhaps this could spiral into
a into a civil war obviously we must
understand the reality is that uh the
the military with with all its guns has
a big advantage they could very well use
violence to reach their aim to restore
stability but it must also be understood
that there are many people who are sick
of the military who are sick
of all the uh the autocratic rule that
has been imposed on them for so many
decades
who desperately want to transition to a
democracy even with all the trouble that
brings and we have seen economic
collapse over the last few years
in sudan the currency collapse the
the hikes in prices for fuel power food
and other commodities for now
communication with people inside sudan
is somewhat difficult because the
military has cut and restricted
telephone and internet networks but one
refugee from sudan that we've spoken to
says this latest military takeover boots
ill for his country
it was a surprise for us we didn't
expect that it would come to this
because all the sudanese people expected
sudan to move in the right direction
towards democracy the entire nation had
such high hopes but the military always
imposes its power on the people
we were shocked by the news that the
prime minister senior ministers in the
sovereignty council and other important
officials had been arrested we received
some messages from our brothers despite
the internet and other communications
having been cut the disagreement between
the military and civil officials is very
important because the glorious december
revolution dethroned the old regime and
helped to create the new government we
were counting on the new government to
create a civil state
you